americans have gotten so divided along
political lines in recent years it's
like we're not even living in the same
country we're the same time period
literally and that's not just impacting
your social media feed data scientists
have found that this is starting to
influence major economic data points
i'll break down how we know just how big
the partisan divide in the u.s is how
this is affecting economic reports that
policy makers rely on and how this could
be affecting the u.s economy let's get
into it
data show that americans have high
savings less debt and there are
literally more job openings than at any
time in history all signs of a healthy
growing economy but we found out that
u.s consumer sentiment in february was
the lowest it's been in more than a
decade so what gives this may have more
to do with perception
than reality a recent report from the
university of michigan finds that
partisan views now dominate consumers
economic expectations
and perceptions of the economy between
republicans and democrats are the most
divergent they've ever been the readings
have reached a staggering new level
under the past two presidents a 52-point
gap between republicans and democrats to
put that number into perspective the
difference between how americans rated
the economy at its highest point in the
university of michigan survey
when the u.s was booming during early
2000
and when we were at its lowest point
during the inflation-driven recession of
1980 was only 46 points republicans and
democrats today have more different
opinions of the economy than americans
who were in the middle of an economic
boom and those who were suffering
through a staggering recession here's
how that's impacting the economic data
that policy makers rely on listen
confidence matters
investors retailers manufacturers banks
the government they all look to this
confidence data to give them clues about
what's coming next in the economy this
also matters for inflation expectations
for inflation are one of the biggest
factors in actual or realized inflation
and right now in the university of
michigan survey we're seeing republicans
expectations of inflation
way above democrats expectations of
inflation in fact republicans
expectations may be too high while
democrats expectations may be too low
here's how this is affecting the u.s
economy weak consumer confidence has
historically led to a decline in
consumer spending and we've seen that
over the last couple months if that
continues that can lead to lower
consumption which drags economic growth
lower that's especially important in a
consumer-driven economy like the united
states businesses look at these consumer
sentiment readings too low consumer
confidence numbers can cause
manufacturers to decrease their
inventories in advance they might even
delay investing in new projects or
facilities banks see these numbers and
they can prepare for reductions in
lending like mortgages and credit cards
now none of that is to say that there
aren't real issues hurting consumer
sentiment right now i spoke to the man
who literally wrote the book on reading
economic indicators bernard bommel chief
economist the economic outlet group he
tells me that the depressing impact of
covid19's omicron variant and the rising
cost of living have had a notable impact
on sentiment those are the real factors
he says everything else is kind of fluff
but fluff is moving the needle this
hyper partisanship can lead to a vicious
circle of negative outcomes for both
sides according to richard curtin who
put together the university of
michigan's report richard tells me that
democrats are more likely to make poor
investment decisions because they think
the economy is better than it is and
take too much risk republicans with low
confidence are more likely to not invest
in things like starting a business
because they think the economy is worse
than it actually is as we've seen when
it comes to inflation confidence and
investment
perception impacts reality in curtains
words people have moved from economic
evaluations to political evaluations and
that's making the job of economists and
investors that much harder
if you enjoyed this video hit the like
button and if you're interested in
markets make sure to subscribe as the
elder chuck d once said they claim that
i'm a criminal by now i wonder how some
people never know the enemy could be
their friend guardian in short don't
believe the hype
i'll see you next time